reunimos a siete actores yo soy actor yo
soy actor yo soy actor yo soy actriz yo
soy actor yo soy actriz soy un gran
actor seguro de mí uno es un mentiroso
si el grupo descubre quién es el
mentiroso ganará un premio en efectivo
si el mentiroso sobrevive gana todo el
premio
este es el impostor
cuando te diste cuenta de que quería ser
actor en segundo grado a los
10 años cuando estaba en la universidad
haciendo así que alguien decide tan
mayor que quiere ser actriz a no ser que
esté loca
como la que hacemos ahora
tengo una serie web llamada siri hero
network o google
network vistieran ventas juntos una
serie web llamada
un programa de televisión juan strange
happy lo saque de amazon y tenemos un
acuerdo con
el intérprete a un sujeto siniestro
ahora vamos yo hice un comercial de
colgate yo algo el corporativo yo hago
que estoy en una película de amazon
prime yo estoy en asuntos corporativos y
no quiero decir nombres
muy rápido
es como si quisiera culpar a otra
persona tratando de que no sospechamos
de él parece actriz suena como actriz
pero pareciera que no busca precisamente
la actuación
cuando dijimos cuando decidimos
convertirnos en actores fue la única que
tomó esa decisión cuando era mayor
está bien ya el papel más corto de mi
carrera
fue un sujeto siniestro en el programa
en wang wang en fox tal vez no les
parecía tenebroso lo cual es halagador
quisiera pensar que todos me vieron y
pensaron ese sujeto no es siniestro es
un buen hombre qué papel les ha gustado
más interpreta estuve en un episodio de
wonderland smolders e hice el papel de 1
mes y no es el mismo el que ve en la
película de terror pink cree fue muy
divertido
el mío es el que hago actualmente
interpretó a un loco héroe de acción y
hay muchas peleas y esas cosas y la mía
fue una comedia para ver fumados fue
julio
él es muy callado no participo en la
conversación y fue muy muy vago yo
estuve en un episodio reciente de gmail
actúe con williams
sí sí sí sí creo que estuvo en vez de
una buena pregunta él tiene una
fascinante energía no parece que
estuviera conectado la industria del
entretenimiento en el entrenamiento
asisten a alguna escuela de actuación se
sitúa a nivel de clases en ese mes y si
santa mónica como si bien es genial eso
eso es todo o quieras en el futuro creo
que aprendí lo que necesitaba aprender
así que ahora sólo estoy audicionado
como verdadero claro muy bien me parece
muy todo el tiempo
así
hay algo en el que no se siente bien él
no parece que formará parte del grupo
hizo que me preguntará si sabía de que
estábamos hablando
trabajo como actor soy un gran actor
seguro de mí así que
para todos así que también producimos
iguales si tienes razón están
familiarizados con romeo y julieta
pero acaso no es la luz que alumbra esta
ventana es el oriente y julieta es el
sol salve yo sol y mata a la luna
envidiosa que está enferma y pálida de
pena pero tú la que no
error leer líneas juntos es una buena
manera de saber si eres actor porque
puedes emocionarte en el momento
adecuado mientras lees es como decir que
sabes lo que haces sólo la usan los
bobos y la desecha
es mi dama es mi amor y ojalá lo supiera
o romeo romeo donde estas que no te veo
muy bien
[Risas]
[Música]
hubo un empate entre dos personas molín
y reid ayer tendrán que votar de nuevo
[Música]
bien lo siento puedo votar de nuevo
[Risas]
[Música]
ah
lo lamento me vale
enviamos le mucho amor si sienten que
expulsaron al impostor terminamos el
juego si sienten que todavía está en la
caja deberían el nivel 2 y levanten la
mano si siempre deberíamos vivir así yo
pienso que si nos sorprenderemos al
final estábamos vibrando teníamos una
gran energía y fue lo que me desconcertó
eso fue lo que en realidad me alertó si
las luces se ponen verdes
eliminaron al impostor si las luces se
ponen rojas el impostor sigue en la caja
crees que el elimina si vamos
muy bien ahora el impostor de un paso al
frente
y así está bien
que yo no lo hice bien supongo que
muchas veces no lo puede ser bueno y
dice que todos me rechazarán
creo que debía haber ganado debí ganarme
el premio porque los engañe a todos
básicamente actué mejor que todos y les
garantizo que si preguntáramos quién era
el impostor todos me habrían elegido a
mí al principio estaba avergonzado
porque pensaba demonios es tan obvio y
luego los vi dividirse y dije oh esto es
fantástico en cuanto al entretenimiento
me alegra haber salido rápido me habían
descubierto no puedo actuar y si tuviera
que leer algo de romeo y julieta lo
habría sabido en el acto me sentí poco
preparada para el humo y julieta le soy
sincera cuando hablamos de cine teatro y
luego shakespeare estoy muy orgullosa de
todos los demás de todos menos de mí
porque yo no sabía quién era el impostor
el primer programa de juegos en el que
participo y la primera vez que gano así
que uno de uno
así que si soy el ganador y detesto
decirlo pero actúe y engaña a todos en
el escenario
[Música]
y
tienes